there's a beauty and a beat who can make
my own please
yeah that's Billy Eilish singing Justin
Bieber and it's gonna make your freaking
day justin bieber's you know I made it
with the ether the 17 year old singer
covers elves women and music October
issue opening up about learning to be
herself in the music industry
quitting Twitter and battling depression
quote I'm in the happiest place of my
life and I didn't think that I would
even make it to this age and Billy's
happiness is totally contagious cuz we
got all the happy feels while watching
her game of song association with the
mag they gave her a word and she had to
sing a song with the word in the lyrics
Billy sampled a little pink her and
Miley Cyrus but the best part was the
Biebs oh and she kept going a Justin
Bieber's you know I made it with the
ether runs out Weiner of course it's no
secret that Billy has been a longtime
fan of Justin back in March she dished
to et about her love for the singer
when did your love for the Biebs starts
um you know what it started when I was
like 12 I believe and that was like
right before he retired what did you
have posters in your room I did yeah big
ass she also admitted that the pop star
had deemed her honey could you have so
many celebrity fans Julia Roberts Haley
Bieber just posted about you is anyone
sliding into those DMS yet I mean Bieber
did what did he say you have to say
you'll have to see your one day you'll
find out but that was crazy
um the thing that he actually no the
first thing he sent was a screenshot of
a DM I sent him in 2014 at the time
Billy hadn't met Justin yet but in July
she revealed that dreams do in fact come
true when she announced
she and Justin had recorded a new
version of her hit single a bad guy to
promote the track of Billy shared this
throwback pic on Instagram that's Billy
standing in front of a wall covered of
photos of Justin she captioned the post
quote OMG FG anything is possible man
Justin shared the same pic writing Billy
Eilish so proud of you remix from the
bad guy let's play Billy singing Bieber
one more time shall we
beauty and who can they God I love me
some Billy Eilish and you can count on
us to bring you all the latest Billy
News so make sure to keep it locked
right here on e T until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]